one of the reasons that the gun debate
in this country is so contentious is
that there's very little good data on
who owns guns and what share of guns
used in crimes are illegal guns and part
of the reason there's not good data is
because the debate is so contentious in
the first place but you know one
proposal that I like a lot is to create
kind of a national firearm Safety
Administration something like the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration Nitsa which collates
transportation data so if we want to
know about what really causes you know
there's still 30 to 35 thousand traffic
fatalities a year it's a lot considering
how much we drive it's not that much but
it's that's a lot of death the more we
know about how every accident happens
the better we can do at preventing
similarly with something like guns the
more we know about how guns are used how
they get in the hands of the people who
use them for crime you know the vast
majority of guns are never ever ever
ever used in any crime so you know that
I think is a really useful way to look
at what data can do I think right now we
have people on the gun on one side of
the gun debate saying you know we need
our guns for whatever and you know
leave us alone the other side saying all
guns are terrible and you need to take
them all away
both those arguments would seem to be a
little bit naive but we can't really get
to a better place because we don't have
the data I you know I grew up in I
personally grew up in a gun culture I
grew up in upstate New York where most
families had guns for hunting target
practice whatever the vast majority of
people I knew never use their guns for
any crime most laws that we make to
protect people from guns are usually
ignored by the criminals and obeyed by
the law of IDing people and so I think
that if you had better data there'd be
no one more in favor of it than law
abiding gun owners because they don't
want to be smeared and lumped in with
the criminals who use guns so that's
where data can be a kind of different
tool in the arsenal when you're trying
to make better policy or public policy
because
otherwise you're just kind of shouting
at each other with your ideology rather
than understanding how people actually
behave